I'm going to start today doing something
that maybe you will find surprising
which is I'm going to praise something
that the Trump administration did even
if indirectly the CDC is run by Donald
Trump's selection dr. Robert Redfield
the CDC under the guidance of Trump's
pick put together a fantastic document
about how to open the economy safely now
you might be wondering I don't know
David I saw that guidance that Trump
promoted it seems pretty stupid actually
it doesn't seem that good and you would
be right I'm talking about a document
that was suppressed by the Trump
administration and has only seen the
light of day because it's been leaked
this is a guide to reopening that's been
in the works for weeks
it contains really good specific
detailed guidance for different types of
businesses and organizations restaurants
verses churches verses childcare it's
detailed it's put together by
professionals and it was done by an
agency run by a Trump selected appointee
it's all fantastic except that the
documents were covered up by the Trump
administration to see that they never
actually see the light of day this is
almost as big a scandal as Trump's
bungling of the medical side they have
good guidance for how to reopen the
economy this is what we've been looking
for dr. Robert Redfield worked on this
for weeks at the CDC showed it to
doctors like dr. Burks and dr. pouchy
Redfield even approved it by email but
it was disappeared never to be seen it's
now been leaked to The Associated Press
by CDC staffers who did not have
permission to publish it
they knew the right way to reopen the
CDC put hundreds thousands of total
hours into this and they're just
ignoring it because the optics wouldn't
be good now by the way not I don't want
to get off track but even the guidelines
that the Trump administration did put
out about how to go to phase one almost
all of the states that have reopened
have not actually achieved the guideline
that supposedly you need to achieve to
go to phase one that's a different story
the document that the CDC put together
would have saved lives there are all
sorts of businesses that want guidance
for how to open correctly and the
guidance is different in a restaurant
than it is in a church so for example
they had a guide with advice for
restaurants and it includes lists of
exactly how bars should be cleaned pay
special attention to food contact
surfaces and how bathrooms at
restaurants and bars should be dealt
with it addresses the issue of physical
menus I've tweeted before the physical
menu is a cesspool of germs that should
be eliminated altogether it talks about
continuing to use disposable utensils
even for people who start to eat in the
restaurants this is really good stuff
tailored specifically for restaurants
but Trump just wants things wide open so
this guide was smothered and covered up
it has different guidance for churches
for example actually tailored to
churches for example everybody over age
2 should wear a mask at church period
Trump doesn't want that getting out
there put up signs all over the building
the church synagogue mosque whatever so
that people see the social distancing
guidelines wherever they look it
encourages video streaming or drive-in
services suspend a choir if your
community of faith has one because
people standing near each other singing
is a great way to spread droplet singing
spreads them more than talking these are
really good specific Rock
recommendations and it all went in the
trash now one other note which is the
cover-up
Trump's press secretary Kaley maca nanny
or McKenna knee said Friday that these
guidelines were not actually approved
but we have the emails to prove that
they are as early as April 10th dr.
Redfield of the CDC was sharing this
document with Trump's inner circle
includes Brooks and foul Chi
on April 24 he again emailed the same
documents to Burks and others and said
just look it over so that we can publish
it the CDC was good to go they had
approved it and they were just waiting
for the Trump administration to give
them the go-ahead with
never came and of course the Trump
administration insisted via multiple
emails you are not authorized to publish
this this is not okay to publish so this
is where we really are getting to kind
of the crux of what we're dealing with
right now
Trump handling this well from day one
would have saved lives I've talked about
what should have been done somewhere
between March 5th and March 10th it's
not this pretend game where I was never
gonna shut it down on January 29th when
we had no cases or almost no no we're
not saying that but we are talking about
March 5 a coordinated 50-state response
that would have saved a lot of people
now a lot of people on the right don't
seem to care very much about that but it
would have helped the economy as well it
would have helped have to prevent some
of the economic damage that we're now
seeing if we had a coordinated 60-day
50-state stay at home guideline starting
on March 5 on March 7 March 10 it would
be over by now we'd be past 60 days we
would be reopening potentially with the
guidance of the CDC document which was
thrown in the trash it's infuriating but
it's also tragic it's tragic
in terms of the life lost and in terms
of the economy and it all could have
been handled far differently without
having to go to these outrageous things
like no one shuts a country when you
have one case I agree but what about
when you have 221 cases like we did on
March 5th that's a different
conversation they don't want to have
that conversation